the area that I grew up in sometimes the
gun is the only way to protect yourself
yeah anti gun you don't you don't want
nobody to have guns but then that's
gonna put my family at danger the pool
to the left I'm gonna have all my
pro-gun people go stand on the edge of
that light and all my anti-gun people on
the other side first statement is I
think my views on guns could change
oh I feel like anyone's views can change
on things so I'm kind of surprised that
nobody felt like it could change at all
I don't think that I could change
completely to like the other side but I
would definitely be open to like looking
at it from a different perspective I
think that my stance is very
accommodating to both sides that said I
feel really solid about kind of what
I've learned and what I think is
possible so I feel really solid about
that although I'm you know open to
accommodating for people's needs you
know people's wishes with their rights
my name is Erin Clayton after the
Orlando shooting I realized that my
community was very much a target I had
to get involved to do something
sometimes I think people on the other
side of the issue don't care about me or
my loved ones lives I mean the area that
I grew up in and why come from a lot of
you may not be able to understand that
sometimes the gun is the only way to
protect yourself we all believe there
should be certain rules to get in them
but on my side of the earth there is no
gun laws my name is a sunny hill
regardless of whatever you say there's
always gonna be guns there's always
gonna be violence in the world and I got
family protect I think y'all don't care
about me or my family you know I think
we all care about you know each other
there's others you know the loved ones I
don't care about yeah I'm trying to
protect me in mind that's that's my
reason of saying that nobody else cares
about it because I'm pretty sure y'all
have the same insight like your anti-gun
you don't you don't want nobody to have
guns but then that's gonna put my family
at danger
I don't want that's not at all
I think they're feeling the pro-gun
people a lot of times are like well it's
never gonna be solved like John Rollins
never gonna end and like it won't it
won't and you're absolutely correct but
there's a bunch of ways to decrease it
I've been in a situation in which my
life was in danger I grew up in st.
Louis so we'd go downtown where there's
a huge amount of violence where Home
Depot and this guy's starting to gather
around my dad's truck and I'm in it
alone I'm 14 years old and let he just I
had to put my dad's gun out while I'm
shaking and they just set it on my lap
and to show that it ended up potentially
violent potentially robbery you know I
don't think people automatically are
born or like I Pro cut like I think what
you experience in your life makes you
that way my name is Sarah it wasn't
until recently that my opinion changed
on how I felt about guns and then I
became pro-gun in order to protect me
and my future family
I was never pro-gun before and then some
guy broke into my place and raped me and
I couldn't run away I can do anything
like literally had to lay there and take
it but I knew that if I had a gun at
that point of time on my nightstand I
would have defended myself I think
America has a problem with mass
shootings yeah I think we all should
step forward for that one
it'd be ignorant to say it's not an
issue like I don't want anyone to die
like I don't want to see these school
shootings I don't want people to get
hurt
we're all for protecting ourselves but I
think like when guns are not in the
right hands then it becomes an issue
and I don't think any ways support that
at the end of the day so you all for
like stricter gun laws or no there's a
point where it goes too far I don't
think I need to take a five thousand
question questionnaire for a
psychological test you know but like
isn't that worth it and like I'm not
saying that that's necessarily what we
would definitely do or whatever but like
a five thousand questionnaire or like
people's lives but something wouldn't
you rather would you be willing to go
through the same process to get an
automobile training licensing yes is
renewable yeah yeah but not a
psychological test I think it doesn't
have to be so extensive what you sing
but it's sad how someone can come in to
a gun show and have a lot of money buy
whatever they want show a little maybe a
little card or something and get like
maybe 20 guns and no one's asking you
just because you have money a simple
background check can just do a lot for
people but I also think that a lot of
people like because they don't want have
the conversation about gun violence and
they switch over and say like oh it's
mental illness and like that needs to be
talked about too but gun violence is a
separate issue that also like really
needs to be talked about if my life was
in danger
I would kill yeah can I walk faster no I
do I think I would have liked it in I
don't know if I would anyone you would
not nobody nobody has it in them until
the moment comes yeah like literally
fear doesn't even become a thing anymore
yeah like it disappears and it's like
fight or flight yeah like and you either
freeze and die or you make
yeah and after that another day I'm
gonna make it some people don't got it
in them you can always just you know
shoot them in a place where they won't
be able to move yeah yeah let's do some
people thing but when I went to uh I did
my Karen conceal class they said if
you're trying to shoot him in the leg
you have enough time to get away or to
realize you're not in danger
now your life isn't in danger you know
and so they said you know if you're
pulling that gun out you're shooting
somebody you're shooting to kill I guess
I just I don't understand I understand
fighting for your life that's why I came
to this to the center for sure but like
all this talk about like how to protect
ourselves how to be in these situations
but it's like again we're just
increasing guns and I I keep just one I
want to bring us back to like how can we
combat this from the other end I don't
want to carry guns I don't want to have
guns in my club I don't want to I want
to be there to dance I don't want to
have a firearm on my leg and like but
yeah but you're taking the right away no
no but we'll wait if I can prove to you
that there are ways to enact gun reform
that will decrease the amount of guns
out there increase education and not
hurt the ability of law-abiding citizens
to have access to firearms would you be
willing to discuss ways to do that yeah
like I said I'm all for education but I
don't think like at the end of the day
like if someone's trying to kill me I'm
gonna kill them I'm okay so that's but
that but that is you're allowed to right
now you're allowed to have that gun and
so we keeps kind of saying what we're is
already in place this is already
possible to have all of these guns how
can we start looking at this and you
know changing our minds and our Congress
our government you know leaders minds
you guys keep talking about education
but that is not a reality in that it
we're not allowed to instill reform that
gives us gun education so it's just like
layman's ideas batting around ideas on
how to kill how to kill I'm over all
against violence at the end of the day
I wouldn't need or want to have a gun if
there wasn't violence in the world
sometimes it's a right because it's an S
necessity sometimes so how do we change
how do we do that where we start
changing the conversation where people
don't immediately relate pro gun to or
don't you know that pro gun can equal
pro gun reform well I mean that's why
we're here that's why we're all here
we're all risking something by saying
something I always taught that don't
ever like state your opinion on hot
topics because you're just asking for it
at that point but I feel like you have
to speak up because being silenced being
just as guilty I think the society needs
to learn to speak like educated people
need to sit down come together and talk
about things you guys have something to
say and we said it and we accept all of
each other's views I told you we would
not leave hating each other all right
everybody that's right hey guys I'm
Amari I'm Taylor nice to meet you we
disagree sometimes and it's okay because
this is middle ground
we hope you guys liked it and we hope
that we can continue to bridge people
together through videos like this please
let us know in the comments what side
you fall on and what your thoughts are
tell us why you believe what you believe
yep Jubilee yes and if you want to see
any more middle ground Apicella to let
us know what you want to see you guys
have the best ideas let us know what you
guys think cool and until next time
subscribe I'll see you guys later
perfect high-five